hello everybody and welcome back to the
new series on my channel where we go
over all six Titans in titanfall 2 I
list do their weapons counters and kits
and then you give me your opinion on
whether you want to use them or not in
titanfall to today's episode we're going
to be talking about scorch
scorch is a flame based Titan whose job
is to control the movement of other
Titans and pilots by covering choke
points with flames and thermite now that
we're done with his introduction let's
talk about some score choose weapons and
abilities scorch carries 8203 thermite
launcher which ignore ignites the target
area with thermite and is good for
blocking off areas and choke points just
like every other Titan scorch has four
different types of gadgets and abilities
the firewall which fires a directed wall
of thermite in the direction that you
look a thermal shield a shield which
melts incoming fire and burns nearby
enemies if they get too close and
incendiary trap which fills the area
with thermite ignitable gas which can be
blown up when shooting at and finally
his flame core for scorches core he
slams his fist on the ground and it
releases a thermite shockwave that will
kill anything in his path scorch also
has four abilities which are wild fire
launcher which increases the amount of
thermite from his to3 his t 203 launcher
making it do more damage temper plating
which decreases the amount of self
damage he takes from his own thermite
Inferno shield which increases the
damage and duration of the thermal
shield and lastly fuel for the fire
which makes the firewall last longer now
that we're done talking about his
abilities let's talk about some of
scorches counters scorch being a Titan
who has lots of health it doesn't have
too many counters the problem is more of
when your traps and firewall don't even
affect the enemy and all you have left
to do damages your grenade launcher so
always keep in mind when you're fighting
a Titan to always either have a firewall
or incendiary trap handy at all times
for when the situation doesn't really go
your way now that I have displayed to
you the weapons personal gadgets
abilities and counters for scorch leave
a comment down below whether you would
like to use scorch in the future or not
I hope this video was very informative
if you do it enjoy leave a like like I
said before comment your opinion on
whether you would like to use scorch
just by hearing this data or not and if
you're new around here subscribe I have
done
four different or three different Titans
now I still need three more Titans to do
so I'm going to be keeping the series
going and I have plenty more ideas for
titanfall 2 so stick around for that
guys and peace out guys have a great day